reescribe la expresión 5 por 9 4 usando
la propiedad distributiva de la
multiplicación sobre la resta después
simplifica vamos a reescribir esta
cantidad aquí para que se note mejor 5
por 9 menos 4 aquí podríamos evaluar lo
del paréntesis y después hacer la
multiplicación pero nos piden usar la
propiedad distributiva por lo que vamos
a distribuir este 5 con esta cantidad y
con esta otra y después haremos la
operación así que 5 por 9 5 por 9 menos
5 por 4 si recuerdan en el primer vídeo
de la serie de la propiedad distributiva
explicamos por qué esto es válido porque
esto es válido porque tenemos el mismo
resultado si aplicamos la ley a que si
hacemos la operación tradicional y de
todas maneras al final vamos a evaluar
la operación tradicional para verificar
que nos da el mismo resultado 9 por 5 es
5 x 4 20 45 - 20 es igual a 25 25 y este
es el resultado usando la propiedad
distributiva de la multiplicación bueno
supongamos que no hubiéramos querido
usar la propiedad distributiva de la
multiplicación que hubiéramos hecho
bueno esto nos queda como que nos queda
dentro del paréntesis bueno nueve menos
cuatro es cinco y esto lo vamos a
multiplicar por el 5 que está aquí
afuera 5 por 5 es igual a 25 que es el
mismo resultado que obtuvimos acá uno
fue usando la propiedad distributiva de
la multiplicación y el otro simplemente
evaluando la expresión